évolution de l'épidémie de kovy de 19
avec cette audition l'objectif des
sénateurs est de comprendre comment le
recours aux passes vaccinale a été
décidé nous partons tout de suite pour
la salle rené monory sur les échanges à
tout à l'heure précise se fonde nous
espérons que votre parole sera précisée
libre à nous avons entendu aux
collaborateurs qui certes ont une vision
globale et l'art de la synthèse mais on
ne peut pas dire qu'on a été noyée sous
les détails
donc je vous laisse la parole ya pas de
s y attendait j'ai pas la troisième
place voilà je vous demanderez vous
exprimer en quelques minutes maximum
afin de laisser le maximum de temps aux
échanges et je demanderai à chacun
intervenant et commissaire d'être concis
dans les questions des réponses puisque
nous disposons d'une heure quinze je
vais maintenant conformément à la
procédure applicable aux commission
denquête vous demander de prêter serment
je rappelle que tout témoignage
mensonger devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire est puni de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé et monsieur olivier verront
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité
j'ai la main droite et dit je suis jeune
je vois là je vous laisse la parole
monsieur le ministre bien la même
résidence à catherine de roche mesdames
et messieurs les rapporteurs sur chantal
de seine michel ou meunier et olivier
henno mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
peut-être qu'ils sont avec nos visions
je vous remercie pour votre invitation
ça me permet de rendre compte devant
vous de la mise en oeuvre du pass
vaccinale et de m'exprimer sur son
adéquation à l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire lié à l'épidémie de lakovic 19
permettez moi tout d'abord de rappeler
en quelques mots les circonstances de sa
mise en place à la mi décembre 2021
lorsque la transformation du pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale a été
décidé notre pays était confronté à une
situation sanitaire
qualifiées de très préoccupante
caractérisée par un variante delta qui
était situé à un plateau élevés associés
à des tensions hospitalières déjà
importante tant en termes
d'hospitalisation conventionnel que de
soins critiques nous étions par ailleurs
confronté au début de la circulation du
fameux variant omicron dont nous ne
savions pas encore énormément de choses
avec détails sinon qu'il avait engendré
une flambée de contaminations parmi les
pays confrontés est plutôt que le nôtre
à cette nouvelle forme de sascoc 2 face
à cette situation compte tenu de
l'efficacité de la vaccination pour
réduire les formes graves
intégrant la nécessité d'une dose de
rappel le gouvernement a décidé tout à
la fois d' amplifier les mesures de
protection dans des lieux à risque et
d'inciter encore davantage à la
vaccination en transformant le passé ni
terre en passe vaccinale il s'agissait
de recentrer le dispositif sur un schéma
vaccinal dit complet contre la co lead
pour permettre l'accès à certains
établissements et lieux recevant du
public
cette décision reposait fondamentalement
sur l'état des connaissances sur le
virus et les mesures adaptées pour
lutter contre l'épidémie en particulier
le rôle majeur pleinement étayé de la
vaccination pour protéger et limiter les
conséquences une forte circulation du
virus accélérée par la période hivernale
ainsi que par la contagiosité accrue du
variant mikron face à un tel niveau de
circulation du virus le pass and i ter
ne permettait pas de prévenir la
présence de personnes non protégés
susceptibles de développer des formes
graves dans des lieux associés à un
risque accru de contamination
cette décision s'appuie aussi sur le
retour d'expérience du pass sanitaires
et ses effets importants sur la
dynamique vaccinale au cours de l'été
2021 en vérité ne s'agissait pas d'une
rupture dans notre stratégie mais du
prolongement logique presque naturel
c'est j'ose dire dupas sanitaires tels
qu'ils avaient été mises en place par la
loi du 31 mai 2021 plus étendue par la
loi du 5 août dans le cadre prévu par le
législateur nous avions d'ailleurs
renforcé progressivement l'incitation à
la vaccination en mettant fin à la prise
en charge intégrale et généralisée des
tests de dépistage virologique c'était
la mi-octobre en réduisant fin novembre
à 24 heures la durée de validité des
tests de dépistage admis dans le cadre
du pass sanitaires en d'autres termes il
était pleinement cohérent sur le plan
sanitaire de franchir une étape
supplémentaire dans le soutien à la
vaccination compte tenu des
circonstances épidémique est dès lors
que la vaccination permettait de réduire
durablement et efficacement les
conséquences sanitaires une forte
circulation du virus elle avait même
déjà été franchie dès la fin septembre
pour les déplacements en nouvelle
calédonie la loi autorisant déjà ce
dispositif pour lui ni pour ce qu'on
appelait le pass frontières je rappelle
par ailleurs que cette évolution a été
complétée par d'autres mesures de
gestion de crise et de près nage prise à
court terme face à la cinquième vague je
pense notamment au renforcement des
mesures de prévention aux règles
d'arriver sur le territoire national
depuis l'étranger ou vers les outre-mer
ont recours au télétravail ou au
développement massif du dépistage
pendant cette période autrement dit la
transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale a constitué l'une des
réponses à l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire dont il ne faudrait pas
surestimé l'ampleur par rapport au
dispositif antérieur et qui ne devrait
pas conduire non plus à omettre qu'il
s'agissait de l'un des éléments de
l'arsenal juridique mobilisés pour
répondre à la crise sanitaire dans
certaines auditions je sais que d'aucuns
ont regretté que le pass vaccinale ne
soient pas mises en place plus
rapidement mais dès lors que le
dispositif relève du domaine de la loi
pour le pass 10 activités l'adoption
d'un test d'un texte législatif était
incontournable pour le pass vaccinale à
ce titre permettez moi de souligner
qu'entre l' annonce faite par le premier
ministre je crois qu'ils étaient le 17
décembre et la présentation du projet de
loi nécessaires à sa mise en oeuvre en
conseil des ministres il n'a fallu que
dix jours dix jours écoulés ce qui est
je le dis une prouesse institutionnel
qui a nécessité une très forte
mobilisation de tous les services
concernés ainsi que du conseil d'état
saisi dans des délais extrêmement
resserré en outre le texte a été examiné
en commission par l'assemblée nationale
dès le 29 décembre ce qui est tout à
fait exceptionnel le temps requis par la
navette parlementaire puis par la
saisine du conseil constitutionnel nous
a amenés à pouvoir mettre en place le
pass à compter du 24 janvier c'est à
dire juste après sa promulgation depuis
cette date dans les différentes
catégories d'établissements et de lieux
prévus par la loi du 22 janvier il est
désormais requis de présenter la preuve
d'un schéma vaccinal complet un
certificat de contre indication pour les
personnes concernées ou un certificat de
tablissements pour les personnes ayant
été récemment infectés en outre depuis
le 15 février le délai dans lequel la
dose de rappel doit être effectuée à
compter de la dernière injection pour
conserver un schéma vaccinal complet a
été ramené à quatre mois nous sommes le
22 février avec une durée d'application
d'à peine un mois et alors que ce
dispositif est toujours en cours de mise
en oeuvre le recul manque encore pour en
faire une évaluation complète rigoureuse
chacun peut l'entendre peut-on néanmoins
considéré que le pass actional à
contribuer utilement à la lutte contre
l'épidémie oui incontestablement
il nous a permis de renforcer la
protection d'un certain nombre de lieux
de brassage et de progresser sur la
primovaccination d'une partie de la
population tout en favorisant une
campagne de rappel massive pour celles
et ceux qui avaient déjà complété leur
schéma vaccinal en moyenne plus de 30000
primo-injection ont ainsi été réalisées
chaque jour entre le 8 et le 15 janvier
2022 c'est à dire un niveau record par
rapport à l'automne depuis la mi janvier
2022 la dynamique s'est atténuée mais
nous réalisons toujours en moyenne douze
mille injections par jour tout primo
vaccination supplémentaires c'est une
bonne nouvelle c'est un progrès en
matière de protection individuelle mais
aussi collective en particulier pour nos
concitoyens qui présentent des risques
de développer des formes graves les
complétion de schémas vaccinaux en cours
ont également enregistré une
augmentation à la suite de la non du
dispositif passe en un rythme moyen de
25000 complétion par jour en novembre et
début décembre à plus de 35000 fin
décembre et début janvier ce qui
démontre l'utilité qu'a eue le pass pour
accompagner l'achèvement des parcours
vaccinale de celles et ceux qui
s'étaient engagés plus tardivement dans
cette démarche et qu'ils aient hésité à
la mener à son terme
enfin en matière de rappels nous avons
connu une augmentation considérable du
rythme d'injection entre fin novembre et
début janvier à la suite des différentes
mesures prises par le gouvernement
plusieurs journées ont ainsi dépassé 600
mille voire 700 milles injection
quotidienne au total au 20 février 38 5
millions de personnes avaient ainsi fait
leur rappelle contre 18 millions au 17
décembre c'est à dire plus de 20
millions de nos concitoyens ayant
effectué leur appel en l'espace de deux
mois grâce à cette couverture vaccinale
très élevé les effets la cinquième vague
la vague omicron sur notre système de
santé ont pu être contenu sans avoir à
prendre de mesures de restriction
généralisée à l'averse de certains pays
européens
je vous propose vraiment regarder de
près on appelle le benchmark sur les
différentes mesures et fermetures
compter mise en place chez nombre de nos
voisins la vaccination nous permet
également de procéder sereinement depuis
début février à l'assouplissement
progressif des mesures
des mesures de freinage tout en
conservant un niveau élevé de protection
contre les effets du virus le 2 février
les jauges ont ainsi été levés dans les
établissements culturels et sportifs
accueillant du public assis et le
télétravail n'est plus obligatoire mais
reste recommandé en laissant aux
entreprises le soin de maintenir le bon
niveau dans le cadre de leur dialogue
social interne le 16 février nous avons
franchi une nouvelle étape
d'assouplissement concernant notamment
la consommation debout dans les
restaurants et les débits de boissons
ainsi que la réouverture des
discothèques le gouvernement a par
ailleurs annoncé qu'une évolution du
protocole sanitaire en population
générale sur les mises en oeuvre à
compter du 28 février s'agissant de la
doctrine de dépistage ainsi que du port
du masque dans les lieux où le pass est
appliquée compte tenu de l'amélioration
de la situation sanitaire enfin nous
avons indiqué que si cette trajectoire
positive se confirmait en particulier
sur le plan des tensions hospitalières
et en terme de circulation du virus nous
pourrions envisager une levée du pass à
la mi mars dans tout ou partie des lieux
où il est mis en place il est important
de procéder par panier parce que nous
voulons accompagner l'évolution de
l'épidémie sur le plan épidémique mais
aussi sur le plan hospitalier nous
voulons conserver une grande prudence
une certaine progressivité dans les
prochaines semaines pour prévenir de
nouvelles contaminations du fait d'un
relâchement trop rapide des mesures dans
la période actuelle
permettez moi à ce titre de rappeler que
si la circulation du virus a fortement
diminué depuis plusieurs semaines notre
système de santé lui reste très exposé
c'est l'occasion pour moi de saluer à
nouveau l'engagement de tous les
personnels soignants mais aussi non
soignants de tous les établissements de
santé sociaux médico-sociaux qui sont
extrêmement mobilisés depuis deux ans
pour soigner et accompagner toutes
celles et ceux qui le nécessitent
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voici en substance les éléments qui nous
ont conduits à mettre en place le pass
vaccinale la situation actuelle et
perspectives qui se présente à nous vous
l'aurez compris c'est toujours avec
l'objectif premier d'assurer la
protection des français que nous avons
agi et avec le souci de prendre des
mesures proportionnées à la situation
compte tenu de l'évolution rapide des
connaissances sur ce virus et la
dynamique de l'épidémie dans le contexte
le passé ni terre devenue passe
vaccinale dans la plupart des lieux et
pour la plupart des publics qui étaient
soumis à permis d'enrichir le panel de
mesures de prévention mobilisés pour
lutter contre la circulation virale en
renforçant les mesures de prévention
pour la fréquentation de ces lieux en
soutenant la vaccination il a pleinement
contribué à l'objectif de protection de
la santé de nos concitoyens
seul objectif qui nous guide depuis le
début de la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire et c'est avec optimisme
mais aussi avec vigilance que nous
continuerons d'être pleinement mobilisés
dans les prochaines semaines je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
passer la parole au rapporteur
auparavant sauvé un point lorsqu'on a
fait les premières auditions
on a compris qu'en fait le
transformation du sanitaire en passe de
l'acte final est un
moyen en effet de booster la vaccination
et notamment de ne pas recouvrir un
vaccination obligatoire dont le contrôle
n'est pas forcément évident est-ce que
vous pouvez confirmer un peu ce
ce que l'on nous a dit et je vais passer
la parole au rapporteur
olivier merci monsieur le ministre
quelques questions vous avez abordé
cette question du pass vaccinale si vous
pouviez préciser les indicateurs qui
vous permettent de suivre cette utilité
notamment les trois principaux peut-être
et puis regardez risque des restrictions
qu'ils impliquent le gouvernement at il
mis en place des outils pour suivre les
effets du seul passe vaccinale sur la
situation sanitaire ça c'est le premier
heureux vague de questions deuxième
vague sur la situation hospitalière vous
l'avez abordé aussi mais en particulier
combien de plans blancs sont encore
aujourd'hui active et combien
d'établissements sont encore contraints
à des déprogrammations est selon-vous
sous quel délai celle ci serait telle
résorber je remercie
les réponses d'ores et déjà un
rapporteur par rapportà l'obligation
vaccinale on a beaucoup débattu c'était
une option qui était sur la table vous
savez qui d'ailleurs vous pouvez
dépasser les clivages politiques
traditionnels j'ai compris d'ailleurs ce
débat je vous rappelle qu'elle était les
arguments qui avaient opposé d'abord
c'est les outils de contrôle j'ai bien
compris que parmi certains y compris au
sénat qui proposait l'obligation
vaccinale quand on parlait de contrôle
et de sanction c'était plus ou moins
automatique et c'était surtout moins que
plus donc c'est à dire l'obligation
vaccinale obligations sans contrôle et
sans sanction c'est pas une obligation
et c'est une star de pieux et donc
quelles auraient été les dispositifs et
ce qu'il fallait les attraper un sonnet
la porte des gens ou faire des contrôles
dans la rue aléatoire mettre des amendes
de 100 euros est ce qu'on peut
considérer que quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
est très très éloignées des systèmes de
santé ferait partie de ces dispositifs
de contrôle probablement non puisque si
l'on isolé tous les systèmes de santé
qui n'ont pas vu leur médecin leur
pharmacien alors qu'ils n'aient leur
infirmière leurs collègues leur famille
etc qui n'ont pas été sensibilisés il ya
peu de risques qu'ils ne soient un peu
de chances qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
contrôlés puis pour celles et ceux qui
sont les plus opposés qui sont dans une
forme de complotisme à vis à vis du
vaccin poulard être une amende de 100
euros si l'on a l'impression que le
vaccin va transformer leur sang en
espèce de pâte molle qui va envahir leur
organisme ce jour aussi très mais c'est
parmi les choses qu'on peut voir de
temps en temps évidemment une amende
vous n'aurez pas eu d'impact sur ces
gens là et puis l'autre l'autre critère
c'est que le lobby sûr mais ça n'aurait
pas n'a pas que tout de suite et en fait
il fallait agir tout de suite c'est à
dire quand la vague delta étaient très
hautes et que la vague omicron était en
train de monter et si on avait mis en
place une obligation vaccinale on
l'aurait fait comme les autres pays on
aurait dit dans trois mois et donc on
serait aujourd'hui en train de se poser
la question de la mise en oeuvre
pratique de cette obligation vaccinale
avec les conditions de contrôle et
éventuellement sanction donc on sera
arrivé après la bataille
sur les indicateurs de reparler
quels sont les indicateurs le premier le
principal c'est que les hôpitaux on
retrouve un mode de fonctionnement
normal ça veut dire que plus personne
n'ait appelé par l'équipe médicale ou
chirurgicale pour lui dire désolé on a
plus de place parce que les pales atco
vite dans l'ide réa on peut parler au
père et on va décaler sa de trois
semaines
c'est à dire plus de déprogrammation les
hôpitaux qui me déprogramment plus c'est
une bonne nouvelle j'étais à nice la
semaine dernière l'équipe médicale me
disais depuis deux jours on a repris une
activité normale enfin une activité
normale comme avants locaux vides ça
veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas des des
manques d'effectifs pour faire tourner
des blocs opératoires et terrain je
confonds pas les deux mais c'est pas la
charge encore vide qui aujourd'hui
impact l'organisation des soins il ya
encore des hôpitaux où ce n'est pas le
cas il ne pardonnez moi de dire très
difficile de vous donner des chiffres
sur le nombre d'hôpitaux qui sont encore
en plan blanc sur le nombre précis des
programmations on suit cela le plus
possible en interpellant les
établissements il y en a énormément et
donc je peux pas vous faire un état des
lieux précis par contre je vous dire
qu'il ya encore une charge sanitaire qui
est très importante plus de 2900
patients kovy denrées à choisir plus de
50 % des lits de réanimation de pays
sont déjà occupés par des patients
atteints du coc vide donc vous êtes sûr
qu'il ya un impact sanitaire et quand
j'étais encore pas loin des 30 mille
patients atteints de kobe dans les lits
d'hôpitaux dans les lits de médecine
vous savez que vous avez encore un
impact important sur fonctionnement des
hôpitaux donc ce que nous disent les
scientifiques le conseil scientifique
s'est classé que il faudrait qu'on
redescende aux alentours de 1500
patients kobinan real
pour qu on considère que le
fonctionnement normal les hôpitaux
seraient restaurés ce qui à ce rythme
pourrait intervenir d'ici deux à trois
semaines puisqu'on est en diminution de
la charge sanitaire en réanimation
autres ministres en aient dit qu vite
c'est vraiment les patients covin et non
pas le bien sûr alors y'a des patients
pourrait avec codic vous avez raison de
souligner il ya un écart qui peut être
conséquent s'agissant des patients
hospitalisés en soins qu'on en soins
conventionnels en soins critiques
l'écart est beaucoup plus restreint et
il a tendance à se réduire évidemment
puisque moins de virus circule moins
vous avez de risque de tomber
aléatoirement sur un patient qui est là
pour tout autre chose et qui est un dico
vite une deuxième indicateur rapidement
à c'est la dynamique épidémique est là
le conseil scientifique nous il faut que
le facteur aire de reproduction du virus
sont durablement inférieurs à 1,6 soit
sur une pente décroissante et qu' on est
atteint un niveau de taux d'incidence
qu'ils soient assez faibles entre 300 et
500 aux plus forts au maximum pour
pouvoir considérer qu' on a vraiment
franchi le plus dur on va l'atteindre et
là aussi je pense qu'on atteindra d'ici
deux à trois semaines maxi ce kit bonne
nouvelle on voit qu'elle a de la décrue
de l'épidémie on voit là les sorties
d'hospitalisation néanmoins il ya eu pas
loin de ne pas dire de bêtises mais il
ya encore pas beaucoup de buts c'est
hier qu'ont été enregistrés crois que
c'était 290 et c'est ce qui est
pardonnez moi de lire beaucoup
c'est 10 % de la mortalité routière
annuel
les gens ont le sentiment que
quand on écoute parler de la pandémie en
ce moment c'est pareil en france et dans
le reste du monde en tout cas en europe
mais homologue 20 me disait le décompte
du quotidien des décès
est une donnée qui ne paraît plus
centrale dans l'esprit n'est un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens alors qu'en
réalité le virus c'est aussi le sait
l'impact principal en réalité de faire
perdre la vie aux gens qui sont dans des
attaques graves à la base et qui meurt
quand j'entends sur des plateaux de télé
des gens dire on a bien vu qu'au micro
ne donnait pas de cas graves excusez moi
mais une maladie qui fait 250 morts ou
280 morts sur une journée dans notre
pays il n'a pas beaucoup
il n'a pas beaucoup
donc le convient de continuer d'écrire
par contre on a un effet de protection
populationnelle grâce à la vaccination
donc je vous ai dit charge sanitaire
hospitalière capacité des hôpitaux à
fonctionner le plus normalement possible
une très forte réduction du taux
d'incidence est une dynamique épidémique
qui restent baissières sont les critères
dont nous tenons et tiendront compte
quels sont les effets du pass sur la
situation sanitaire il m'est impossible
de vous répondre c'est trop tôt ça fait
un mois c'est trop tôt je peux vous dire
sur le plateau axial pardon ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que des études qui
ont été publiés que dans j'ai pris
connaissance vous aussi très
certainement sur l'impact du pass
sanitaire déjà à l'époque sur le nombre
de vies sauvées sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations éviter sur le nombre
de réanimation qui ont été évités et le
chiffre est extrêmement élevé
extrêmement élevé je sais pas si mon
équipe me l'a amenée c'est l'analyse du
conseil d' analyse l'étude du conseil
d'analysé économique publié en janvier
2022 qui
considère qu'on a gagné 13 points de
vaccination en france et donc ils tirent
des conclusions sur la sur lol la fin de
l'année 2021 4000 décès évités par le
pass trente mille 30 demi
d'hospitalisation éviter 45% d'admission
en soins critiques évitez
donc je considère que le pass actional
aura un effet positif sur la situation
sanitaire mais je ne peux pas vous
répondre actuellement c'est trop tôt
voilà je réponds
oui sur les déprogrammations on entendu
ce variable d'un hôpital à
à l'autre et on n'a pas d'idées moi je
suis toujours un peu surprise je vous le
dis mais du manque de d'indicateurs qui
quand on dit
combien il ya de
de
déprogrammation qui n'est pas bon c'est
pas vous qui êtes forcément en cause
c'est parce que parce que c'est pas
nouveau mais comment on n'a pas pu
mettre en france et des tableaux
d'indicateurs sans qu'ils soient
journalier ou matin midi et soir c'est
parce qu'on demande mais qui est quand
même une vision globale de combien
personnel sont en place combien sont
absents et quand on pose la question on
la pose et l'autre jour à la dg os on
est du bon à faire des études adresse je
trouve ça un peu un peu un peu un peu
bizarre oui voyez qu'on est quand même
est-ce qu'il ya un moment est-ce qu'on
va réussir dans ce pays à avoir des
indicateurs on a même chose dans
l'éducation nationale
des enseignants ne sais pas où ils sont
et je peux pas interdire je plussoie
vous avez raison c'est factuellement ces
raisons je j'arrive j'arrive à la tête
d'un ministère qui fonctionne très bien
très fort il ya des tonnes de données
mais des données manquantes on l'a vu
quand on l'a vu lorsqu'il eut cette
fameuse polémique sur les lits fermés
souvenait il suffit que quelqu'un dise à
bahia 20% au doigt mouillé à 20% de lits
fermés pour que pendant un mois on nous
nous on ne fasse le buzz que là dessus
et que je me retrouve mois en situation
défensive de devoir répondre à une
affaire une allégation qui étaient
fausses mais il a fallu dix jantes et
des enquêtes spécifiques à organiser des
remontées de donner pour arriver à
démontrer que ces allégations étaient
fausses et il s'est écoulé plusieurs
semaines c'est la même chose vous avez
raison madame la présidente sur les
déprogrammations alors par contre
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
plus nous voulons de données précises en
temps réel
remontez traité nationalement plus cela
implique de charges administratives et
le discours ambiant que auquel j'adhère
ne va pas plutôt ne veut plus tôt pas
vers le sens de il faut plus
d'administratif dans les hôpitaux mais à
chaque fois que vous demandez une donnée
et les gens qui les recueillent un et
sur le tour des blocs opératoires d'un
hôpital multi sites pour savoir combien
de déprogrammation été faite à combien
de temps quand est ce qu elles sont
refaites et c'est que tera est ce que
c'est lié aux coûts d'autres choses vous
bouffer des frites des équivalents
temps-plein fait sa foi mille hôpitaux
et montre avec des milliers d'emplois
administratifs donc on allait donner on
est content après mais pas donc on est
plutôt dans un pilotage résonnait
pragmatique on sait que lorsqu'il y a de
la via dei utilisant des indicateurs de
processus qu'on les consultations
d'anésthésie ont cédé compter est-ce
qu'il ya plus ou moins de consultations
d'anesthésiques la même l'année dernière
à la même époque et c'est donc c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à se faire une une
vignette une focale sur la situation
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre avant la promulgation de la loi
vous aviez annoncé lors d'une conférence
de presse avec le premier ministre une
levée progressive des restrictions et je
pense entre autres au 6 février et au 16
février pour la réouverture entre autres
des discothèques sur quelles bases
scientifiques
auxquelles vous fondiez vous ces
annonces je voulais vous interroger sur
le seuil de 1500 lits en soins intensifs
mais vous y avez répondu c'est parfait
je est-ce que vous avez des éléments
soul sur le sou variant ba2 quelles sont
les évolutions
possibles est-ce que vous avez des
simulations est ce qu'il y à des risques
de retomber dans une épidémie qui nous
qui nous déborde et puis une réflexion
je m'étonne que depuis une dizaine de
jours que ce soit dans les journaux
presse-papier pièces écrites ou journaux
télévisés on a très peu n'a plus
d'informations sur la situation
sanitaire en france alors que dans les
deux années qui ont précédé on avait
tous les soirs des choses assez sinistre
on nous disait il ya 8 152 morts l'erea
explose on est à cinq militaires
est ce que c'est une volonté
est ce que le voilà le virus a disparu
et on retourne à une vie normale je vous
remercie
sur le dernier sujet sur la place dans
l'agenda public que peut prendre
l'épidémie ses conséquences ne revient
pas de vous répondre je ne suis pas en
charge de l'un de ceux qui doit faire
parler ou non je continue de communiquer
j'ai fait une émission ce dimanche il a
été question du colis temps une demi
heure j'ai fait une émission quelques
jours auparavant il était question est
quasi exclusivement du de de l'aco vise
l'épidémie il on nous répondons à chaque
fois que nous sommes s'est interrogé
joue encore jeune des revues de presse
ou d'imaginer quotidienne et je vois
qu'il ya encore une place consacrée il
ya une forme de lassitude et puis une
forme de rassurance on est plus inquiet
lorsqu'une vague va taper et lorsque la
vague est passé auquel est en train de
passer de la même manière à chaque vague
on a eu cinq entre la vague commence à
monter vous avez pendant dix jours les
hôpitaux nous tiendrons pas et des lits
fermés et ses acteurs qui après on se
rend compte que les hôpitaux y tienne
puisque nos soignants sont incroyables
et puis on ne parle plus de la situation
ce qui t'a bien donc il est toujours une
mise en tension de de l'opinion qui ce
qui est fait mais de chèques par
l'épidémie elle même n'y a pas de
volonté au début d'une vague il ya forme
de relâchement qui s'opèrent lorsque les
gens se se trouve plus rassuré il est
clair qu'à la fin décembre je vais vous
dire même rapportage eu des moments où
on se poser des questions avec le
variant mikron on savait qu'ils étaient
très très contagieux qui avaient circulé
très vite je les dis en toute
transparence je vous voulez fermer les
bars des restaurants ça ne sert à rien
il circulera regardez les pays bas pays
bas ils ont tous fermé en veut pas se
prendre cette cinquième fargo mikron
donc ils vont pas prises puis quand ils
ont ouvert bas ils l'ont prise
l'allemagne l'a eu aussi de façon
décalée et c'est donc il nous il y avait
une marge tout il ya toujours cette
forme d'incertitude et cette forme
d'incertitude elle crée aussi dense y
était c'est évident que si quand une
bague démarre vous êtes capable de dire
il ya une vague mais on va avoir tant de
cas mais on va avoir temps
d'hospitalisation les hôpitaux tiendrons
et aux médias - de mise en tension mais
on n'a pas la réponse au moment où la
vague commence c'est le propre d'une
épidémie avec des virus inconnu et qui
sont capables de varier bouger pour ça
que je reste toujours très prudent jeudi
on a fait le plus dur parce que je le
pense sincèrement
mais je n'exclus pas qu'ils aient
d'autres variantes qui puisse émerger ça
ou là sur la planète avec des
caractéristiques totalement différentes
et qui nous imposent de revenir sur des
dispositifs que nous sommes en train
progressivement d'alléger et ça je vous
dire ma conviction les français l'ont
parfaitement compris ils n'ont
parfaitement compris donc il est moins
nécessaire peut-être d'aller chercher de
l'information quand on a parfaitement
appréhender les tenants et aboutissants
d'une épidémie comme celle ci sur les
quels sont les critères d'allègement les
critères là heureusement que nous
regardons ce sont des critères généreux
on va avoir des des pires objectifs aux
mesures de freinage d'abord on a voulu
lui on veut limiter les risques de
clusters de contamination diffuse
massive on veut éviter que sur un jour
donné il y ait des pleins d'endroits
dans le pays où il ya des centaines de
gens qui puissent se contaminer sont les
établissements recevant du public en
grand nombre lorsqu'un virus circule
très fortement qui est en forte
croissance on sait qu'on risque d'avoir
ces clusters et qui peuvent entraîner un
échappement du suivi de la patte de la
maladie et ensuite on veut éviter que
les gens qui sont très fragiles même
s'ils sont vaccinés se retrouve en
contact proche avec des gens qui sont
pas vaccinés et vaught anciennement
contaminants d'où la logique de
l'obligation vaccinale par exemple des
soignants et des mesures que nous nous
conservons puisqu'elles sont toujours
valables même quand le virus circule
moins il ya d'autres mesures dont les
conséquences sont supérieurs aux
bénéfices escomptés lorsque nous sommes
dans une dynamique plutôt de
ralentissement et de freinage de
d'épidémie le variant mikron a traversé
la france c'est près de la moitié la
population on peut le considérer comme
ça qui a été contaminé donc dès lors
vos d'immunité populationnelle acquis et
en plus de la vaccination dès qu'on
pouvait tout à fait anticiper une
réduction du virus et donc par an par
anticipation des mesures d'allègement ce
qui a été fait d'ailleurs ans au
printemps 2020 parce que le prix dans la
république annonce par anticipation que
le 11 mai soit ramené confinement c'est
tous nos tableaux de bord c'est tout
c'est tout le modèle l'institut pasteur
les courbes qu'on est capable de suivre
on l'est on a des courbes comme ça qui
nous qui nous qui nous présente qui me
pour l'avenir puis nous chaque jour on
met des points et on regarde c'est le
temps sur la courbe ou pas et si elle
tombe sur la courbe qu'elle voit juste
c'est là que les cours les modélisations
bien prédit ce qui allait arriver
eh bien on poursuit dako mais on sait ce
qui va se passer dans une semaine dans
deux semaines en trois semaines pour ça
je me permets de dire que d'ici à la mi
mars peut-être un peu avant peut-être un
peu après nous aurons atteint rempli les
critères qui nous sont aujourd'hui
demandé avant de pouvoir alléger le port
du masque à l'intérieur enfin et le pad
vaccinale dans tout ou partie des lieux
qu'ils appliquent aujourd'hui
sur ba2 les dernières simulations on
n'est probablement pas loin des 50% du
variant circulation qui est du variant
ba2 il ressemble vraiment c'est vraiment
nouveau le plus que le cousin germain
c'est pas le clown non plus mon fort on
va dire que c'était un peu un siamois
c'est cherche une métaphore partout dudu
de l'eau mikron
et nous voyons que nous considérons les
scientifiques considèrent qu'il n'ya pas
de risque qu'il y ait un rebond
épidémique et tu fais du bea 2 c'est
tout ce qu'il fallait savoir
merci maintien monsieur le ministre
j'avais une question mais vous y avez
quasiment répondu c'était sur ce qui se
passe chez nos voisins européens et vous
avez parlé de benchmarking vous avez
donné quelques exemples donc je
considère que vous y avez répondu sur
les mesures que vous envisagez de lever
elles sont aussi en fonction de ce qui
se passe chez nos amis européens non moi
je reste ma question des plus fragiles
des plus vulnérables peu concitoyens on
a entendu jeudi dernier monsieur niox
château nous dire vol était un peu moins
optimiste que vous dans les chiffres
nous a unis 5000 vaccinations par jour
pas douze mille aujourd'hui vous parlez
vous / dr lee oui oui oui mais quand
même
conséquent de plus au rendez vous mais
pas exhaustive mais c'est quand même
symptomatique est
comment dire ce qu'on entend beaucoup
c'est que bon d'accord j'aurais ma
troisième 12 normalement affaires en
avril mais bon puisqu'il y aura plus pas
ce à quoi bon et on a comme sa perte de
chance qu'ils risquent voilà de s'opérer
donc sur cette population donc là je
parle d'une catégorie de personnes
autrement les personnes fragiles immuno
déprimées par exemple qu'est ce que vous
comptez mettre en place quand il y aura
cette levée pour continuer à les suivre
et à les accompagner dans leur santé
merci
d'avoir encore une fois des décisions de
mesures de freinage et on en a beaucoup
débattu au parlement et c'est normal ont
un impact sur l'ensemble de la société
le pass vaccinale a soulevé de
l'opposition de la crainte parfois de la
colère on peut comprendre tout ça ça
empêche pas d'en comprendre et d'en
saisir pleinement les raisons pour
lesquelles nous l'avons mis en place et
pour les cadets et aujourd'hui encore en
place cela étant à chaque fois qu'on
peut lever une mesure vécu comme une
contrainte pour la population nous
devons faire et nous le faisons et nous
est déjà arrivé d'enlever de proposer
dans le masque et puis lorsqu'il ya une
bague supplément d'une bague l'intérieur
de nortel remettre
c'est cette situation là elle est
vraiment adapté elle est proportionnée à
la situation sanitaire et la situation
épidémique et comme nous pouvons retirer
entreront oui retirer le pass vaccinale
à la en mars peu
peut-être avoir un impact sur quelques
milliers de français qui aurait poussé
jusqu'à la vaccination troisième
d'autres enfin en numéraire je suis pas
certain que ce soit ce soit phénoménal
continue du rythme actuel de vaccination
de rappel pour être tout à fait franc
avec vous je pense que le gros vraiment
le très très gros qu'on pouvait gagner
interne de vaccination de couverture
nous l'avons acquis nous l'avons gagnée
donc il est possible de lever cieux mais
ça n'empêche pas de continuer à les
vacciner y compris en primo vaccination
les personnes les plus fragiles et plus
éloignés et qui vont continuer ce
travail du quotidien fait par les
équipes pour aller chercher les gens et
d'en proposer le vaccin pour les
immunodéprimés en un traitement et la
france a été le premier pays ou en
europe au monde jeu sésame et en europe
à mettre à disposition des patients on
en est à plus de on en a près de quinze
mille patients traités par et du shield
quel traitement préventif on ait
également des anticorps monoclonaux
curatif plus de 4000 patients traités on
est au pacs loving à plus de 1500
patients traités et donc on a des
traitements qu'on met à disposition
destinée notamment aux plus fragiles aux
immunodéprimés ce sont les victimes qui
ne doivent pas être les victimes
invisibles de cette pandémie on a
toujours dit il ya deux profils de
patients en réanimation et les non
vaccinés et les immunodéprimés
j'avais une question c'est justement sur
ces rappels bon
au départ c'est vrai qu'on pensait avec
une dose une première dose la deuxième
dose avant après et on partait pour une
protection l'ongle ce qui n'a pas été le
cas mais ça on ne savait pas départ et
maintenant on est sur un effet sur une
troisième dose que l'on préconise à
quatre 4 mois maintenant un moment ait
eu des débats sur la quatrième de sa se
pose en israël notamment qu est un peu
en avance sur nous
on peut comprendre que cette perspective
de doses de vaccins répéter puisse
puisse inquiéter inquiéter notre nos
populations et vous l'avez jouer me dis
qu'il ya une forme de vaty de fatigue
vaccinale et qui fait pour l'instant est
pas question de 4e d'autres en même
temps quand on a dit ça ya pas de
données scientifiques voiliers qui
explique que quatrième dose non parce
que les gens sont fatigués c'est c'est
peut-être entendable sur le plan
psychologique c'est speed et ou
sociétaux sociologie mais assez peu sur
le plan sur le plan scientifique
ça c'est un point et puis le deuxième
question que souhaitait poser rené paul
savary mais je le vois pas connecté on a
entendu l'an dans le cadre de cette
mission santé publique france et lors
d'une audition la directrice nous
indiquer qu'elle était chargée de
collecter d'agréger les données
épidémiologiques mais qu'elles n'avaient
pas pour mission d'être associés à des
décisions de gestion de crise
et qu'elle n'avait pas aussi notamment
de sollicitations
spécifique pour le passage du passé ni
terre ont passé vaccinale
hors la loi sinde des larges mission à
santé publique france
donc je voulais savoir comment ce fait
les sollicitations par le gouvernement
de santé publique france pour éclairer
les décisions sur la gestion de crise
est ce qu'il ya un problème de capacité
limitée de la chance dans ses moyens
pour faire face à une crise sanitaire la
cour des comptes a d'ailleurs donné
enfin nous avons demandé à la cour des
comptes d'ailleurs de réaliser une
enquête sur santé publique france pas
par défiance contre santé publique
france mais pour évaluer son financement
son fonctionnement ses moyens et ses
missions et notamment depuis depuis sa
création et depuis il ya eu la fusion
des trois agences qui était antérieure à
sa création mais ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quelques mots là-dessus
bien sûr
j'ai parlé de cette ligue nationale dans
une émission
parce que c'est un concept qui apparaît
dans un rapport qui nous a été remis par
une autorité scientifique chargé de nous
de nous guider un 10 ans est un des
paramètres dont il faut tenir compte
mais c'est pas le cas tu parle à mes
principales je vais être très clair mais
la présidente sylvie invariants
dangereux en circulation et que nous
avons un vaccin efficace qui nécessite
de re/max nié toute la population la
main ne tremblera pas
parce que c'est s'il en va de l'intérêt
de la population la sécurité et la santé
aucun sujet là ils vont tester
différents
fin de vague derrière moins dangereux
très haut niveau de protection vaccinale
de la population très haut niveau de
contamination avec très peu de formes
graves de la population et les vaccins
disponibles encore efficace sur les
formes graves mais en cours de
développement en vue les adapter aux
derniers variante c'est tout c'est
contre ce contexte là fait que ce qui
nous conseillent nous disent il n'est
pas nécessaire de proposer aujourd'hui
la quatrième dose à la population
générale tout simplement et ils disent
par ailleurs ça évitera de renforcer le
phénomène de fatigue maximale qui
séjournent chez certaines personnes
la présidente la fatigue métal jeu je
la grippe on soit une tous les ans quand
on est fragile il ya plus de 10 millions
de nos concitoyens qui tous les ans
vaccinée contre la grippe c'est le
réflexe du mois d'octobre
pardon
parce qu'on n'efface
annoncé vacciner trois fois dans l'année
parce que c'est de sa vie russe qui
donne plusieurs vagues rené facile il
faut dire mais j'ai aussi la grippe
mutent est pour provoquer quatre ou cinq
vagues potentiellement mortelles par an
nous aurions des rappels vacciner contre
la grippe qui serait plus régulier que
ça donc on s'adapte si une chance de
vaccins n'ont jamais considéré que
c'était un handicap il est gratuit il
est disponible partout il est bien
toléré il est très efficace la planète
entière se vaccine j'ai jamais considéré
qu'il faille consiste à y voir dans le
vaccin
une charge handicap ou une malédiction
c'est tout l'inversé et d'ailleurs on
parle sans arrêt de politiques de
prévention dans notre pays n'en fait pas
assez de prévention des dents tout
curatif le vaccin par l'excellence et la
médecine préventive
sur le rôle des space santé publique
france a présenté bing ans n'a pas pour
rôle de prendre des décisions ou
d'éclairer directement ou d'orienter les
prises de décision ça c'est le rôle de
la direction générale de la santé qui
chapote santé publique russian
techniquement c'est un organisme de
veille sanitaire de veille
épidémiologique qui fournit et traitent
des données qui permettent ensuite
d'orienter et puis le décision est donc
normal la directrice générale de santé
publique france
ce n'est pas un avis à rendre par mons 1
600 m à tj vaccinale de notre pays et
encore moins du pass nous avons déjà
voudra pas échappé on a un paysage assez
bariolés en matière d'agencés structures
sanitaires gelé résume ministre de la
santé direction générale de la santé qui
chapote lui-même l'agent sa salle de
sécurité du médicament qui chapeaute
aussi santé publique france qui chapote
d'autres agences d'état vous avez le
ministère vers les ars qui sont les
agences déconcentré chargé de mettre en
place les mesures décidées nationalement
mais aussi de mettre en place des
procédures innovantes et qui ont charge
gérer la vaccination une autorité
indépendante la haute autorité de santé
qui ne répondent pas aux ministres mais
que nous pouvons saisir pour qu'elle
nous remettent en transparence et en
parfaite indépendance des avis
scientifiques que nous avons agrémenté
d'un comité d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale pilotée par le
professeur fisher et et vous le savez
j'ai déjà eu à expliquer cela j'ai
souhaité que ce ne soient pas les mêmes
acteurs qui anticipent évalue met en
place et contrôle je souhaitais qu'il y
ait plusieurs acteurs différents qu'ils
puissent intervenir avec des missions
différentes d'où la création du conseil
scientifique qui est aussi en toute
indépendance et la loi lui a conféré un
statut
chargé d'émettre des recommandations et
de guider les politiques publiques
j'ajoute à cela tous les organes qui
peut au conseil de santé publique
extrêmement près extrêmement utile et
efficace et a donc déjà un paysage assez
assez chargé voilà on va pas demander à
deux agences différentes de la même
mission surtout quand l'une était placée
sous la direction d'autres
questions non pas de questions par ci et
ça me donne
question monsieur vous
bonjour monsieur le ministre merci
madame la présidente c'est vrai que nos
concitoyens sont partagés il ya ceux qui
sont vraiment des pros vaccins et
d'autres qui sont très éloignées moi je
pense qu'il faut continuer la
communication parce que les vaccins on
aura toujours besoin quelle que soit la
maladie qui est en face et donc il faut
continuer la communication et je dirais
que dès le plus jeune âge il faut
expliquer un nous on nous expliquait
tout simplement ce que effet louis
pasteur contre la rage et je crois qu'il
faut continuer dans les écoles a
expliqué combien c'est important et que
c'est pas un ennemi parce que quand on
voit comment certains en parlent mais
c'est
c'est désastreux c'est désastreux parce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont naïfs aussi
et qui peuvent les croire ce qu'il y en
a qui ont vraiment une capacité de
persuasion
incroyable donc il faut il faut
continuer la communication sur sur les
vaccins parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
recherches qui ont abouti par exemple un
des vaccins contre la méningite et on
sait que les parents qui vivent ça c'est
terrible et que l'ice ils sont bien
contents de trouver quelque chose en
face pour répondre à l'urgence de la
réaction sur sur une telle maladie sur
l'enfant donc il faut il faut absolument
communiquer il faut communiquer aussi
sur tout ce qu'on a mis en place pendant
cette longue période vraiment cette
longue période qui nous a fait oublier
d'ailleurs la valeur du temps notamment
sur les l'hygiène moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'on garde des réflexes d'hygiène
dans ce pays parce que nous étions l'un
d'avoir des dd comment des qualités
indienne moi je pense notamment lavage
des mains à la précaution qu'on doit
prendre dans tous les magasins
d'alimentation je crois qu'il faut qu'
il faut continuer à protéger les
aliments parce que quand je voyais avant
cette pandémie que on vous présente des
aliments et que les gens se parlent avec
le commerçant et que là les postillons
passe au dessus des aliments est en
dedans moi je pense qu'il faudra garder
en termes de santé publique cette
réaction absolument est par ailleurs
dans certains lieux et bien il faudra
qu'on s'habitue à mettre encore le
masque dans certains lieux dans
certaines conditions et expliqué
toujours expliqué toujours expliquer
pourquoi je voudrais simplement vous
demandez pas ce que ça m'a été demandé
de la part de sa famille nos concitoyens
à quel moment quelles seront les
conditions pour enlever le masque à
l'intérieur je dis ça ce notamment pour
des personnes qui travaillent et qui ont
des métiers quand même et soufflant dans
des pièces et qui voit là sont un petit
peu inquiet de conserver ma ce que toute
leur vie désormais merci messieurs
ministre
merci pour votre intervention madame un
rapporteur général
la france est dû mettre en place une loi
en début de ce mandat sur l'obligation
vaccinale contre des maladies infantiles
qui aurait dû disparaître et qui
revenait de façon galopante
la france n'est pas le pays loin s'en
faut qu'ils affichent le plus beau taux
de couverture vaccinale contre la colite
les enfants
donc oui nous sommes un pays qui doute
le pays de pasteur d'août a en un pays
qui doute et qui se laissent convaincre
puisque nous étions je leur dis un peu
en moins de 40% je crois d'intention
vaccinale de la population avant la
vaccination de mauricette et puis
quelques jours plus tard surtout quand
la peur de manquer ces faits grande nous
étions montés à 70% et puis désormais
nous sommes un taux de couverture
vaccinale qui j'aurais cru a totalement
impossible à atteindre en début de
campagne vaccinale et si on vous avait
dit que 54 millions de français sur les
vaccinés contre la co lead voit rien dit
c'est un peu ambitieux donc on se laisse
quand même pas contre les enfants ça n'a
pas été le cas alors le contexte
épidémique les gens bons sentiments que
au micro n'est pas grave chez les
enfants que j'étais là je les dis je le
redis il ya des enfants l'hôpital est
statistiquement beaucoup plus enfants à
l'hôpital parce qu'on n'est pas vaccinée
donc je ça c'est un point com qui est un
point fort même un important général je
ne sais pas dans quel autre contexte on
accepterait l'idée que 500 enfants
hospitalisés pour des hospitalisations
évitables ce ne serait pas si grave que
cela finalement voyez ce que je veux
dire
vous avez raison sur les mesures de
sortie de crise sur le maintien de
l'hygiénisme alors je pense que les gens
en ont un peu ras-le-bol qu'on leur
parle de leur santé mais il faudra quand
même conservé un certain nombre de
réflexes je sais pas si un usage humain
on a toujours dit que l'asie était un
pays qu'on regarde et d'ailleurs des
pays d'asie on est regardé avec beaucoup
de sérieux un peu car quilliec parce
qu'il met le masque et quand c'est des
épidémies apparaissent peut-être que
c'est un réflexe que un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens prendront je nous
vois mal à imposer le match en tout dans
tous les cas un hiver parce que la
grippe arriverait mais non moi je
rappellerai qu'en 2020 du fait de la
distanciation sociale nous n'avons pas
eu de gastro non pas une grippe ne l'ont
pas une bronchiolite il ya eu beaucoup
du sol est aussi en dehors de coded avec
ces mesures mais néanmoins il faut qu'on
continue à vivre et je pense que l'ère
de la fin la distanciation social est
bientôt arrivée vous posez des questions
sur le masque en intérieur nous aurons
un conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale peut-être la semaine prochaine
nous verrons qui devra statuer sur
l'état sanitaire épidémique j'en parlais
tout à l'heure et décider de la suite de
l'engagement avec deux grands pôles de
mesure à alléger le pass vaccinale et le
port de masques là où il sera là où il
est encore obligatoire et là où il le
restera à date du 28 février
pour avoir un raisonnement bloc en 10
ans et la suppression ou pour avoir un
raisonnement qui tient compte des de
graduation niveau de risque pour faire
un nouveau palier c'est à dire par
exemple conserver le pass vaccinale pour
les discothèques les bar dansant là où
il ya des risques de clusters et de
contamination qui sont plus important
encore quelques semaines elle supprime
et ailleurs ou maintenir le maintenir
notamment des établissements recevant du
public dans certains grands événements
intérieurs avec beaucoup de monde et
beaucoup de brassage ça peut être une
possibilité je n'ai pas la réponse c'est
l'objet du conseil de défense et de la
saisine des autorités scientifiques que
de pouvoir nous guider et s'agissant du
masque en intérieur il a vocation à
disparaître
dans tout ou partie des lieux fermés il
ya deux questions qui resteront
également en suspens à savoir si on fait
un allié ou non c est ce que on le
supprime partout où est-ce qu'on le
maintien encore pendant quelques temps
précis on a vraiment écrasé virus dans
les lieux à plus fort risque de
transmission qui serait transports en
commun avec une question sur les salles
de classe mais vous imaginez bien que
c'est compliqué je le dis de demander à
des enfants de pour continuer à porter
le masque en classe quand les adultes ne
le porterai plus en entreprise donc cela
nécessite d'avoir une réflexion assez
poussée même très poussé qui enjambe les
questions sanitaires pour aller vers des
questions éthiques et de tolérance
sociétale c'est tout l'objet du travail
que mes équipes fournissent actuellement
pour qu'on soit prêt à proposer dans le
cadre d'un prochain conseil conseil de
défense et sécurité nationale la bonne
marche à suivre pour les dernières
phases des dernières étapes de
l'allègement pour qu'on ait un printemps
non masqué sauf si vous décidez d'aller
danser et était la blague que je vous ai
tout à l'heure aux balles et que l'on
puisse et qu'on puisse revivre le plus
normalement possible
alors pascal connais je crois une
question à distance pascal en
russie le ministre moi je n'ai ça va un
peu sur la sur la recherche en fait sur
sur l'éco vide long mais quand on parle
de covin l'ont bien entendu il y a
les personnes qui ont perdu des
capacités pulmonaires il ya aussi des
tas de conséquences ou peut-être qu'on
met le mot sur ça vient du duc au vide
peut-être que ça ne l'est pas mais
est-ce qu'elle a beaucoup de recherches
là dessus je pense que ça ce sera sur un
temps long aussi pas que le coc jean sur
sur le vaccin
la recherche on va dire d'anticorps moi
je suis pas du tout du milieu médical
alors vous m'excuserez jusqu'à
maintenant on n'a pas en fait la
possibilité de connaître c'est à dire
que bon moi je mettrais vaccination est
ce que voilà je suis couverte longtemps
pas longtemps voilà il sa dépendance des
personnes dont qu'est-ce qui est ce
qu'on aura aussi une réponse là dessus
je dire moins agité vacciner voilà trois
fois trois fois il ya des gens en fait
qui concerne d une protection de manière
plus courtes d'autres longues et puis
ensuite pourquoi il ya des familles qui
passent au travers complètement et
d'autres qui sont tous avec les mêmes
protections on va dire center il ya des
questions aussi qu'ils sont qui sont
posées sur ce sujet et enfin comme vous
avez répondirent un collègue sur et vous
avez parlé des vaccins pour enfants
les médecins traitants et médecins
généralistes et qui rencontrent sont pas
très favorables tant que les enfants
n'ont pas atteint on va dire l'âge de la
puberté donc est ce que là dessus vous
avez
davantage de réponse
oui moi serait une question c'est comme
ça on pourra vous pourrez répondre ça
permettrait de conclure l'audition
c'était sur les 75 cent quatre-vingts
ans et plus est ce que on vous avez quel
est le taux de couverture vaccinale et
michel magne évoqué la question des
immunodéprimés en effet qui sont un vrai
sujet d'inquiétude enfin de
préoccupation du fait d'une mauvaise
mauvais effets du vaccin mais en même
temps une grande vulnérabilité
mais
qu'est ce qui est fait pour aller vers
ces personnes de qui certes ne vont pas
forcément dans les lieux publics et qui
n'ont pas une une un besoin important de
passes sanitaire vaccinale mais qui
néanmoins côtoient leurs aides ménagères
leur leurs familles et et autres et est
ce que quand vous parlez de lever le
pass vaccinale en disant peut-être dans
certains lieux ils seraient maintenus
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez
envisagé le passage dans certains lieux
d'un pass vaccinale à un retour au poste
sanitaire
à l'ars olivier
une dernière question sur l'âge médian
des ddc les personnes qui décèdent du
duc au vide est ce qu'il ya une
évolution et quel est il à la date
d'aujourd'hui
ont pour certains question qui sont
intéressantes j'y réponds on est assez
loin de la commission d' enquête pour
laquelle j'ai prêté serment que là vous
m'interrogez sur l'avenir la science et
de la recherche donc je
je le dis sur kobe blond il ya plusieurs
cas de covile l'ont en tout cas de
symptômes persistants post co lead iliad
est conviviale et surtout qu'ils vont
disparaître au bout de quelques semaines
d'autres vous de quelques mois d'autres
qui vont durer
certains durent depuis 2020 c'est pas le
plus fréquent heureusement mais ça
arrive perte de l'ouïe l'odorat qui peut
durer un peu plus longtemps ces frais du
camp n'auraient reine des tubes à essais
ont fait sentir et ça serait du que le
droit
vous avez des gens qui ont ce qu'on
appelle de 10 autonomie sedrine
dissociation entre le rythme cardiaque
et l'activité qu'ils ont j'ai vu une
marathonienne infirmière de 30 ans qui
tape à 110 pulse e minute au repos ça
peut entraîner une fatigue énorme et une
incapacité de faire des efforts
physiques on ne s'est pas complètement
expliquer mais ça veut dire que le virus
a réussi à s'infiltrer dans des des
fibres nerveuses qu'on ne soupçonnait
pas qu'il puisse atteint et les formes
pulmonaires graves persistante des
insuffisances respiratoires chez des
gens qui ont mis les formes pulmonaires
très grave avec des grosses pneumonie et
des abcès et qu'ils peuvent conserver
des séquelles respiratoires et à
d'autres situations vous avez des
symptômes qui sont plus compliquées à
catégoriser avec de la fatigue de la
stand-up n'aurait pas dû rester ni des
céphalées etc il est difficile de vous
dire aujourd'hui combien sont victimes
de symptômes persistants puisque avec la
vague omicron sar battu pas mal les
cartes et on ne sait pas s'il peut
donner d'ailleurs des colis de long nous
développons nous déployons fortement la
recherche il ya eu deux appels à projets
anrs le premier thé en novembre le
prochain et en mars en premier projet
huit projets ont été dans le premier
appel à projets huit projets ont été
acceptés et on déploie des centres de
prise en charge en tout les territoires
pluriprofessionnelle associant des
médecins des kinés des psycho et pour
accompagner sur tous ces patients tout
anticorps j'ai répondu plein de fois
vers la sénatrice si je joue c'est une
prise de sang et vous allez anticorps
ça veut dire vous avez été en contact
avec le virus et vous avez ce qu'on
appelle une immunité une morale c'est à
dire qu'il ya encore des anticorps en
circulation qui si le virus arrive sont
susceptibles d'agir sur le virus et
contre le virus ce qui est plutôt pas
mal mais si jamais le virus déjoue vos
défenses immunitaires et qui vous
affecte ce qui va être important c'est
l'immunité cellulaire la capacité de vos
cellules immunitaires à fabriquer de
nouveaux anticorps il en faut beaucoup
plus que ce que vous avez deux façons
décédée de l'encens et ça c'est pas le
mesurer la preuve des gens ou attraper
delta bon taux d'anticorps trois
semaines plus tard au micro
si vous avez choisi une prise de sang au
moment où il se rattrapait omicron ils
avaient des anticorps dans le sang par
contre leur cellule n'avait pas à qui il
accorde la capacité la compétence et
c'est ça que c'est la vaccination il dit
à vos cellules voilà comment on fabrique
les anticorps pour ça et je comprends
parfaitement et je suis interpellé
encore hier soir dans une réunion à
vocation politique quelqu'un est venu me
interpellé en me disant tiens mais j'ai
des taux d'anticorps qui sont élevés
pourquoi est-ce que peu fait vacciner
toujours et un rassemblement cette même
répond qu'est celle des scientifiques
la sensibilité individuelle à la coved
où il y en a eu évidemment mais ça pour
tous les germes pour tout l'est pour
toutes les réflexions ya toujours
quelqu'un qui n'attrape pas dans une
famille les autres qu'ils ont c'est très
troublant pour la famille je comprends
pas moi je n'ai pas eu mon mari l'a eu
des enfants de rue ma tante l'a eu la
grand-tante la concierge tout le monde
et moi je n'ai pas eu ça fait pas de
vous un super héros ça fait de vous un
chanceux qui n'avaient pas hugo ville ou
alors vous l'avez une façon
asymptomatique avec des tests négatifs
mais c'est bien passé pour vous le dire
pendant deux ans j'ai zappé la colline
je vais tous les classeurs du pays tous
les services de ré à tous les services
d'urgence je vais partout y compris
autant on n'avait pas de masque dans
l'oise dans le grand test de marseille
vita je n'ai jamais attrapé ou qu'on
finit par sentir fort mais on on finit
par ont pu fini par rattraper un beau
matin sans qu'on sache pourquoi on n'est
pas responsables quand on est malade
jamais et on n'est pas un super héros
quand on attrape pas c'est jusqu'au on a
pu passer entre les gouttes mais là avec
omicron est quand même peu de gens qui
ne l'ont pas eu
c'est pas les médecins madame la
sénatrice qui sont pas chauds pour la
vaccination c'est des médecins mais vous
avez raison de dire que des médecins qui
ne sont pas chauds pour la vaccination
des enfants c'est dommage moi je vous je
vous dise l'espagne est pas très loin
50% des enfants ils sont vaccinés dix
fois plus que chez nous dix fois plus
que chez nous
ça prenne conceptuel que vous disiez
tout à l'heure dans la confiance en la
science dans notre pays cette méfiance
excessive vis-à-vis de la vaccination
comme s'agit des enfants alors même que
les enfants sont les plus à même de se
vacciner je vous dis ça parce que c'est
ce qui fait que dans notre pays on n'est
pas capable de déposer un projet de loi
pour rendre obligatoire la vaccination
contre le papillomavirus qui est
responsable du cancer du col de l'utérus
et qui peut terrasser 700 jeunes femmes
en âge de procréer dans notre pays
chaque année
et ce qui touche aussi des garçons et
des cancers oropharyngés glas et
il faut qu'on ait le débat sociétal
abandonné un peu fort ça a été fait par
m est nécessaire lors de la vaccination
obligatoire des enfants on a vu que ça
avait soupé de la collecte c'est à dire
mais il faut passer outre l'intérêt
c'est l'intérêt de la population faut
jamais reculer derrière son petit doigt
il faut être ferme sur les fondamentaux
scientifiques ce dont j'ai fait
pardonnez moi de le dire preuve de
fermeté en 2020 lorsque un certain
nombre de parlementaires ici comme dans
l'autre chambre ne comprenait pas
pourquoi je ne distribue pas moi même
des plaquettes de chloroquine à tous les
gens qui étaient malades ce qui deux ans
après m'aurait valu je pense un joli
procès en pénal à l'instar de ce qui
s'est passé au brésil et vous auriez eu
raison je ne vois pas de commission
denquête aujourd'hui ni sénatoriales
nimani les députés sur les raisons pour
lesquelles je n'ai pas cédé à toutes les
pressions qui voulaient que je précise
je laisse prescrire n'importe qui de la
flore guinée tout le monde bien c'est
dit c'est la couverture vaccinale dans
la couverture vaccinale de plus de 80
ans on est en une dose à pas loin de 90
% en deux doses à 87% et on rappelle à
75%
c'est les chiffres à date
est-ce qu'on peut passer du passage si
nos passes internes ont d'autant qu'il
faudrait une loi pour ça je vous propose
qu'on ne fasse pas 4e 14e texte d'état
d'urgence sanitaire de toute façon le
temps qu'il soit écrit par les services
compétents à la visée par concéder pas
adoubé par le parlement j'espère qu'on
aura plus du bâton voilà et puis sur le
aller vers madame la présidente on
continue le salaire est nécessaire les
associations les pompiers les médecins
les infirmières à domicile et qui n'est
les tâches à tout le monde donc on voit
quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné on dit
on veut on peut vous vacciner c'est
gratuit ça arrive tout de suite voilà et
on continue d'en vacciner plusieurs
milliers par jour
merci
merci monsieur le ministre
merci à mes collègues bonne journée à
vous et à jeudi
jeudi pour la commission denquête
hôpital
je vous dis monsieur le ministre à jeudi
pour la commission denquête hôpital mais
je me réjouis de cette multi
période pré électorale qu'il me ravit et
je serai toujours là pour vous je vous
remercie pour l'ambiance de cette de
cette commission et ç'a toujours été le
cas avec la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat